Salut, c'est enfin la suite et fin
de cette première expérience mentale
qui a été un succès.
Merci à tous d'avoir participé,
merci à tous ceux qui m'ont aidé,
on y reviendra...
Je suis même déjà en train de
préparer la suivante.
Je vous rappelle rapidement les faits :
à la base c'était une expérience de 1942
que j'ai reprise.
Où le but est de voir s'il y a une
différence significative entre
ceux qui croient aux pouvoirs psi.
PSI : P, S, I et non P, S,Y
comme il y en a qui le pensaient,
mais ce n'est pas ça.
Donc s'il y a une différence entre
ces deux catégories,
les "moutons" et les "chèvres"
sur leurs perceptions extrasensorielles.
Ça a été très difficile d'avoir exactement
le protocole de l'époque
donc j'ai mis le mien en place
pour cette version moderne de 2017.
Qu'est-ce qu'il en est ressorti ?
Générique !
[Musique Générique]
30.000 participants !
Vous avez été 30.000 à répondre.
En fait, vous avez été plus de 30.000 à répondre,
mais je n'ai pris aucune des réponses
qui n'avait pas renseigné son adresse mail.
Puisque le but, en mettant l'adresse mail,
qui n'était pas le but parfait non plus,
parce que chacun peu en créer une...
c'était que chaque personne ne participe
qu'une seule fois.
Quatre personnes m'ont également aidé
à traiter les données ;
des gens qui sont bien plus calés que moi
en Maths
soit à faire leurs propres calculs,
soit à vérifier les miens.
Merci à eux quatre.
Je vous les cite à la fin.
Le protocole de l'expériece que
j'ai mis en place :
il est bien ou il n'est pas bien,
peu importe.
Il est ce qu'il est.
C'est ça qui est important à prendre en compte.
C'est à dire que lorsqu'on va interpréter les données,
il faut garder en compte
quel a été mon protocole.
Mon protocole était le suivant :
- On fait le test en vidéo,
donc on n'est pas en temps réel,
ensemble, l'un à côté de l'autre.
Deuxièmement pour vous faire un  rappel
des symboles de Zener,
je les ai laissés à côté,
dans l'ordre classique :
le cercle, la croix, les vagues,
le carré et l'étoile.
C'était ce petit papier.
Ça peut influencer les résultats,
ça peut influencer sur la manière
de répondre,
en tout cas, c'est un fait :
il était là pour tout le monde.
A l'époque aussi, on leur a forcément
rappelé quels étaient les symboles.
Moi j'avais pris le parti de les mettre
dans l'ordre classique
et de le laisser sur la vidéo.
Encore une fois, c'est quelque chose
à prendre en compte
dans mon protocole,
dans la manière dont je l'ai fait.
Ce n'est pas "bien" ou "pas bien",
c'est comme ça,
ça existe en tout cas.
Troisièmement : personne ne connaissait
l'ordre des symboles sous les bristols ;
même pas moi, puisque j'avais
tout mélangé,
donc personne, personne
n'était au courant.
Donc si jamais je pouvais envoyer
des choses avec des ondes cérébrales,
ou je ne sais quoi...
Impossible de le savoir !
Quatrième chose : toutes les personnes
ne font donc qu'un seul essai.
Peut-être qu'en 1942, les personnes
faisaient plusieurs essais
et qu'on notait les résultats.
Cinquièmement : et ça ce n'est pas une
différence des moindres,
euh...
Les personnes savent à quoi
ils et elles participent.
Je ne suis pas certain que
c'était le cas à l'époque.
Et enfin, sixième chose...
je souris parce que j'ai eu
beaucoup trop de mal à dire cette phrase,
il y a eu plein de coupes là je suis sûr...
Donc sixième chose à...
donc sixièm...
Ah, Pu****
[Rires nerveux]
Donc sixième chose à savoir
et à prendre en compte,
c'est que ce sont les personnes elles-mêmes,
les participants eux-mêmes,
qui ont jaugé de leur degré
de croyance ou non dans les pouvoirs psi.
Ce n'est pas un questionnaire
sur le quel, nous, on a décidé
en fonction des réponses à
ce questionnaire,
c'étaient des gens qui croyaient ou pas
aux pouvoirs psi,
c'était une demande directe.
Voilà ! C'était un rappel,
c'était important de savoir ça
quand vous faites une collecte de données,
il faut aussi savoir quel était
le protocole exact.
Ce n'est pas grave qu'il y ait
des choses "bien" ou "pas bien",
du moment qu'on connait tout le protocole,
comment il s'est déroulé.
Et maintenant je vous fais l'ouverture
des symboles.
Derrière le premier bristol,
se cachait : le cercle !
Derrière le deuxième,
se cachaient : les vagues.
Derrière le troisième se cachait :
le carré.
Derrière le quatrième se cachait :
la croix.
Et, forcément, derrière le cinquième
on avait : l'étoile.
Tout d'abord, l'univers des possibles
est de 120 possibilités.
Donc :
La probabilité que tout soit juste
en essayant de capter dans quel
ordre sont les symboles,
est d'une chance sur 120.
Le nombre moyen d'erreurs commises
est de 3,125.
C'est comme ça,
c'est mathématiques.
On a eu la chance, encore une fois,
d'avoir quelqu'un
qui nous a détaillé tout le calcul
pour prouver ça mathématiquement,
que le nombre moyen d'erreurs
était de 3,125.
On va dire "la ligne du hasard".
Je vous mets ce fichier là
dans la description.
Au niveau des croyances,
c'est à dire des groupes :
j'avais rajouté un 3ème groupe
qui était "les neutres".
Il y a eu 7825 croyants
aux pouvoirs psi,
4287 non croyants,
et 14389 neutres.
Quand on a fait les calculs
et les comparaisons,
les différences significatives ou non
qu'il y avait entre les groupes,
on a essayé sur toute la totalité,
sur la masse,
et aussi en rationalisant,
en faisant une moyenne par groupe
ou essayant, par exemple, de prendre
4287 croyants au hasard
pour les comparer à 4287 non-croyants.
Il s'est avéré que cela nous donne,
à chaque fois, les mêmes résultats.
La finalité c'est que les résultats
sont plutôt homogènes.
Entre les 3 groupes, on a à peu près
les mêmes résultats,
le même nombre d'erreurs global,
le même nombre de personnes
qui n'ont fait que 2 erreurs,
que 3 erreurs,
que 4 erreurs
ou tout juste.
Le fait d'appartenir à tel ou tel groupe
n'a eu aucune incidence
de différence entre ces groupes.
On est sur un nombre moyen d'erreurs de 3,9
sur la totalité des participants.
Donc, un peu plus d'erreurs d'ailleurs
que la ligne du hasard.
Mais dans l'expérience de 42,
c'est ça qui était intéressant,
c'est que les personnes qui croyaient
aux pouvoirs psi
étaient à peu près sur la même ligne
que la ligne d'erreurs probables.
Alors que ceux qui ne croyaient pas
aux pouvoirs psi,
faisaient beaucoup plus d'erreurs
que la ligne d'erreurs globale.
Et c'est ça qui était intéressant,
c'est ça qui était significatif.
Ça ne se retrouve pas du tout
dans l'expérience qu'on vient de refaire ensemble.
Mathématiquement, on peut dire qu'il y a
une différence, quand même, statistique
significative.
Mais significative dans le sens où
elle existe, parce que,
en fait,
elle est quasiment négligeable.
La différence statistique moyenne
est de P=0,0451
Entre le groupe croyant et le groupe non-croyant.
La seule petite chose amusante est que
croyants, non-croyants et neutres
aient fait plus d'erreurs que le hasard.
Peut-être que vous, vous avez envie
d'extirper d'autres choses de ces résultats.
C'est tout à fait possible :
je vous mets tous les résultats, également,
en espèce d'open-source,
dans la description.
Vous pouvez les télécharger
et vous en faites ce que vous voulez ;
vous pouvez les triturer comme vous voulez.
Je vous mets également,
toujours dans la description,
un fichier graphique simplifié
que m'a fourni l'une des personnes
qui m'a aidé, en fait, à traiter les résultats ;
Qui s'appelle Dorian.
Vous pourrez voir dessus
directement les pourcentages
sur zéro erreur,
deux erreurs,
trois, quatre et cinq.
Sur 26501 réponses traitées,
sachez quand même qu'il y a eu
240 personnes qui ont eu tout juste.
Voilà
Ça ne sert à rien,
mais je voulais le dire...
Ça fait moins de 1% des participants.
Et, proportionnellement, le groupe
qui a eu le plus de personnes
qui ont trouvé les 5 bonnes réponses,
c'est le groupe des neutres.
0,94% des neutres
VS
0,85 à 0,86% des groupes croyants et non-croyants
Bon, d'une manière ou d'une autre,
l'expérience de 1942 doit être biaisée
quelque part,
il doit y avoir un élément qu'on n'a pas
ou quelque chose qui doit expliquer...
C'est assez dur d'avoir toutes les infos précises
sur ce sujet là.
Je ne peux pas vous dire.
Néanmoins, j'aimerais remercier vivement
quatre personnes
et ne quittez pas la vidéo parce qu'il y a
des choses interressantes à savoir sur eux...
J'aimerais remercier Nicolas Brion
qui est actuellement à Shangaï,
pour son dernier stage de fin d'étude
en école d'ingénieur,
et qui a checké tous ces résultats.
Merci à Dorian Caudal
qui est de Nantes.
C'est un docteur en neurosciences
qu'on connait bien dans le milieu de la magie
et également du mentalisme.
parce qu'il a écrit un livre sur le "MirAcaan"
le "any card at any number"
un peu comme avait fait Taupe10
ben lui il en a une version euh...
qui est logique, rationnelle
Il a écrit un livre là-dessus,
je vous mets le lien dans la description.
Merci à Ruben de Paris,
qui travaille en biostatistique également.
Et enfin à Jérémie, que les 3 autres
ne connaissent pas,
qui m'a contacté indépendamment,
et je lui ai envoyé aussi toutes les données
de manière indépendante
pour ne pas qu'il voit le travail qu'on faisait,
pour essayer de voir tout ça.
Vous voyez, l'idée c'était de pas se planter.
Donc, au final, croyants,
non-croyants, neutres, pas neutres...
les marges d'erreur étaient
à peu près équivalentes.
On a tous fait "un peu plus pire" que
le hasard en moyenne.
Il n'y a pas grand chose à en retirer,
si ce n'est que... ben du coup...
l'effet "Mouton/Chèvre", euh...
qui est un exemple qu'on prend souvent,
que même moi j'avais pris dans une vidéo,
ce qui m'avait donné envie de faire celle-ci...
n'est peut-être pas si valide
ou valable que ça...
J'espère que tout ce concept là
vous aura plu.
J'en relancerai un autre
le mois prochain,
sur une autre expérience, un autre sujet,
un autre truc qu'on pourra faire ensemble,
et voir ce qui se passe.
Encore une fois, je vous le rappelle,
tout est dans la description
si vous-même vous voulez essayer
d'en ressortir quelque chose d'intéressant
n'hésitez pas à me l'envoyer dans ce cas là.
Dites moi dans les commentaires
le nombre d'erreurs que vous vous  aviez fait.
Qu'on essaye de trouver les personnes
qui avaient tout faux
et les personnes qui avaient tout juste.
Et, comme d'habitude, si cette vidéo vous a plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un pouce en l'air
et à vous abonner.
Rendez-vous très très très bientôt,
avant la fin de la semaine.
CIAO !
[Musique Générique de fin]